this guest is an anytime guest and she's
joining us on this very i guess anytime
is right now
uh her new book is a children's a young
reader's edition of her best
seller for the new york times it's
called wolf pack
and she is a two-time olympic gold
medalist and a fifa world cup champion
author and uh an all-around great human
abby wambach here on the rich eisen show
how are you abby
oh man rich i'm good how are you i still
can't believe that you can talk for
three hours every day
it's like how do you even do it you're
amazing well you know i
i whenever i watched you do what you did
um i thought how in the world do you run
around for as long as you do and then
actually
um execute i don't know so i guess
did i just call myself did i just call
myself the abbey womback of broadcasting
you did did i just do that you did and
i'll take it you know when you get far
enough away from your career
um you forget you just forget and so
you're like yes
you're you're you were just like me
thank you for sure very good thank you
abby i will take that and run with it
um so let's uh let's unpack this a
little bit right here
uh this book based on your new york
times bestseller wolf pack and you
decided to write it for
young people how young people will find
their voice
unite their pack and change the world
i'll give you the floor on why you did
this
abby yeah you know the book wolf pack
that i released a couple years ago
a year and a half now um it did so well
and i am super proud of it but i thought
you know
right now especially there's no more
important time
to hand leadership books to our kids
that
are based and forged in honor
the world feels a little bit
askew or tilted or however you want to
look at it
and i just think it's important that our
kids know
and have other outlets than um
you know media and their social media
and tick tock
to to get their information from you
know my philosophy
was learned from my experience on the
national team
i learned from so many amazing
you know women who taught me not only
everything that i know but everything
about myself right
and i'm still learning to this day i
just i think it's really important
um and my wish for this book truly is
that it can become
the families the new family bedtime
story or bedtime reading
around around the world because gosh i
do think our kids need a little bit of
reprieve from the the current news cycle
that we're kind of in
well abby i got to tell you i am
bringing this home to my kids i've got a
12 year old boy nine-year-old boy
seven-year-old girl
um and um it's it's not easy
living inside you know it's not easy
right now it's very
it's very difficult and so um
discussing about the future and talking
about the future in a positive sense and
how they can
shape it and they can take control of it
when nothing's in their control right
now
at all i think is a valuable message
quite frankly well
and i think that right now especially we
have to
empower and i hate that word it's
overused but we do have to
give our kids the tools to be able to
make decisions on their own right
because at the end of the day
they're going to have to be the ones
that deal with the habits and the
addictions that they create around their
you know usage of social media or their
their devices or whatever it is that
we're talking about you know and i think
that
to be internally motivated and then to
understand the dynamics of what real
leadership is about
it's not just about waking up on time
and
getting to school on time or showing up
under your virtual
class on time it's like how are you
trying to make that experience
as positive and as best for everybody
in that experience as possible it's
about the collective
and i understand that you're not going
to get along with everybody
believe me i didn't get along with every
single one of my teammates
but at the end of the day because they
showed up
and because they were one of the best in
the world at what they did i respected
them
and so i think that we have to go back
a little bit and and uncover and unpack
some of the reasons what what we're
doing right like why
why is it important to to talk to each
other with respect right why is it
important and and essentially you know
this book
my hope is that that the kids in their
worlds
can create and co-create the the
environments that they exist in
which you know in the end i think you
get further along
you have much more success in life when
you have people to do life with
so find your people make your packs and
change the world
abby womback here on the rich eisen show
okay uh who who did you hate as
teammates now let's get it you open the
door
i didn't hate anybody but by the way did
i miss your message about respect did i
did that just go straight over my head
that the sports talk radio host and me
just come out of all of a sudden
it did but you you know and that's why
you're so good okay
i think that it's just important for for
all kids to understand
and especially now like when you turn
your tv on and you see
two presidential candidates that are
just being disrespectful to each other
um you know none of that can be condoned
it's like all of us parents
wanted to turn off the television you
know that used to be a thing that we
would bring our kids into and be like
watch this
you know these are our leaders of our
country and now us parents are like no
no
actually we need to turn this off we are
not teaching our children this
and you know we also have to remember
that this is impacting us as adults
as well um so you know i think
even though this is adapted for the
young reader i think that maybe some of
us parents should go back to the
beginning and take a look at it as well
oh my wife and i didn't even uh
con entertain having our children watch
the presidential debate we didn't but
we're
we're we're we're planning on having
them watch the vp debate oh i mean we're
already discussing that
you know i mean that that's that's what
we're talking about and that's the whole
thing too is that
you know i mean that's an exhale of
from the last several months here abby
you know is that is the fact that that
respect could be politicized as a
conversation
it's
okay here we are talking about respect
and there might be some people
sitting and listening to this saying why
are they being political it's like no
that's not that's not that that's not
it's just because somebody does have a
default of disrespect
that might be your view of this being is
political
but this should be an apolitical part of
our conversation
the issues that you have in this book
wolfpack abby wambach here
this is not a this should not be a
political conversation
yeah i mean like you say tomato i say
tomato sort of thing like it's like
look when when we're talking about life
okay
and we're talking about people we're
talking about the way
we think things should go right way that
we think that the life should
be lived by a single person or or
a whole slew of people like at the end
of the day
like when laws and you live in a country
that determine what happens to the
individual and the collective like
everything is political if you
if you want to get real like specific
about it
but i get it i get that politics the way
that
that that the world feels so politicized
and how it's going to be talked about
and turned around
i do believe that we need to get it back
to a level of
human decency and to be able to
to disagree on
things uh in a manner that is
kind and um that
that isn't you know winner-take-all
attitude
like whatever happened to um
you know we're gonna get some and we're
probably gonna lose some but
in general we're all moving in the right
direction
and we're all getting enough of what we
need um
and that and that's just the the the
struggle that i'm having with right now
so for me in my family i believe and
this is true
that no matter what i think there's
always an opportunity
right there's two ways you can always
look at a situation one with with
positive glasses on
and another with negative glasses on i'm
a solutions oriented person
um clearly i think that things can
change
but i'm not going to be only pointing at
the negative
rather than you know for me what my
family tries to do is
really figure out okay what are things
that we can control that we can solve
that we can have
positive effect so that the outcome
feels good enough to us
right it's not like i want everything
and so
i'm going to demonize the entirety of
the republican party because i'm
sure everybody knows and understands
that i'm a little bit more liberal
at the end of the day i still want to
understand
why folks um you know and
the republican folks that i know the
folks who really care about
that party what they believe in what
what is true so how do we come to the
middle it's like okay i'm gonna focus on
what i feel
is most important to me what i can
control and maybe go about trying to fix
it
rather than just talking crap and
complaining about the things that you
don't have or the things that you are
you you fear you're going to lose like
we have
we got to figure out how we can get back
to some sense of normalcy
um where everybody is is feeling like
they're respected
and not being abused or murdered or
victimized right so
i don't know i could go all day and for
people who like you know want to
complain and gripe about it not being
political like
grow up like everything's political no i
understand
it's about it's about owning your
actions and being responsible for it
instead of just
owning someone for the sake of owning
them i think that's really what things
are becoming like right now
and you know not to get too deep about
it um
you know abby wambach here on the rich
eisen show
um as we know covid finds the uh
weakness
everywhere whether it's your your body
your health your family your
your well-being all of it um in terms of
youth sports
um my my youngest son and my daughter
would already be
a couple of weeks into their ayso season
that doesn't exist right now
i'm wondering what you're seeing about
the effect of youth sports and youth
soccer right now as uh
things because of the success of
you and your cohorts and successors on
the u.s women's national team as well as
hopefully what we're seeing out of
christian pulisic and more
um that we're we're you know what i'm
saying that we're seeing more
attention being paid to soccer in the
united states i wonder what you're
seeing the effect of covet is on
on this yeah yeah i i understand that
in every state there's different
phases that have allowed some kids to go
back to playing soccer and some haven't
right
my biggest concern right now isn't about
um
kids around the country not getting
better
at soccer my my bigger concern is their
mental health
around not getting outside and being
around their friends
and getting active and getting their
blood moving
um you know i've i've talked to a lot of
kids i've done a lot of little
book club things where the kids haven't
been able to hang out with their friends
and that's such a huge component to use
sports some kids
are going stir crazy because they can't
get outside and they can't run around
and they can't feel that
fatigue that that comes only after a
long week of training
um you know that kind of stuff for me
the mental health component to it
feels more um worrisome for me but
i also know that your kids are resilient
they'll bounce back real quick
and you know the the longer and the
better we can be
as a collective to maintaining
some sense of decency for each other you
know wearing masks and
um adhering to the to the rules of your
of your state or your city
governor whatever it is um so that we
can actually get through this
together because you know unfortunately
being so divided right now
we do need to actually come together to
solve this bigger problem
and it seems like that's becoming
evident that is
that's like the bigger problem than the
actual
uh disease itself and
and i think it's a it's like an
experiment in
human relations right now if we could
all just agree to do the same thing
for enough and long enough period of
time to wait this out
people might be able to actually go play
sports um
before the vaccine comes out right like
who knows
and i'm not obviously not a doctor so
take that with a grain of salt
i just believe that this is like the the
most interesting human experiment
of all time and we're failing like
miserably failing as a species
abby womback here on the rich eisen show
uh wolf pack based on the number one new
york times bestseller there is now again
a youth edition i can't wait to bring it
uh
youth readers edition can't wait to
bring this home to my my kids i guess
before i let you go
uh i don't know if you're a fan of
american football uh but you're from
rochester
if so does that mean you're buffalo
bills individual or not at all
this is tough i went through the 90s
with the buffalo bills
i was a teenager when we went to four
straight super bowls
and june and jim kelly
could never bring one home so my heart
is forever
broken by the buffalo bills i think and
it's been
hard for me to follow them especially
because then they were terrible for many
many many many years
yes um so will i be a fair weather fan
you're absolutely right i will be right
if
they continue to keep going well um you
know
then of course i'll support them okay
well let the abbey womback of
broadcasting
tell the actual abbey womback come on
home
the bills are waiting for you they're
pretty damn good right now go for it
go for it i come on buffalo bills let's
go
let's go like keep kicking you know keep
kicking butt
and um maybe one day you'll find me at
the stadium
watching you with the mask on that's it
very good hey abby uh congrats on the
book
um and i meant it uh you are uh an
anytime guest anytime you want to come
on just
you know chop it up whether you got
something to promote or not i
i always enjoy our chats thank you sam
rich you take care man you're back after
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here